the moment I wake up before i put on my
makeup i say a little prayer for you yes
I do I have no idea how the rest of that
song girls I only know that opening line
and I feel like I should know the rest
of it because it's such a great song I
don't know any more of it I feel like
there's so many songs out there that
people are like I know the song but I
don't know the artist like you really
you guys know how long it took me to
realize how many songs were made by like
Frankie Goes to Hollywood like it was it
wasn't until like Zoolander that the
song relax was like Frankie Goes to
Hollywood I was like really like I never
really knew who made that song but I've
always liked it relax don't do with
mm-hmm-hmm whatever the Restless song is
so what's up guys i figure it's been a
little while since we did a vlog reblog
discussion of sorts and i want to let
you guys know that I'm gonna I said like
a month I'm not taking a break for a
month is way too long but I'm going to
take a break for like a week or so and
the reason why is because of some of you
guys know I've hired on of like a few
different editors I've hired on um to
editors I'm in the process of bringing
on a third just to make the workload
easier just to you know make it a lot
easier for me to be able to produce
videos faster because the problem is
right in 10 page scripts every day and
then recording it and then editing it is
time consuming it's so time consuming so
I want to be able to like enjoy life
which I don't think is unreasonable but
um anyway yes so so I'm gonna take a
break for you know for like a week or so
get things sorted out some of it also
has to do with the my little pony video
I was kind of expecting hate I don't
realize that we're gonna be people who
were who are that you know I think they
were like some people who were commented
it felt as though like I had you know
specifically like injured them like I
had hurt them you know like like there
were people who are reacting like iced
or something you know why would you why
would you make this video
oh my god man what's wrong with you it
was it was kind of funny reading some of
those comments on the future reference
if you guys see videos or people dinner
in the comments that they're being you
know egregious or they're being
outrageous [ __ ] like that to them but
you're loud um you know as always guys
I've always you know you guys are always
welcome to voice your opinions tell me
what you do and don't like you know just
be reasonable about it you know people
who use profanity you know I always ban
those individuals that's nothing new
most of the comments get filtered get
marked as spam but the ones that slip
through you know add to me at this point
I'd say that this 2016 guys you tues
been around long enough there's enough
youtube content creators out there I
think it should be standard knowledge by
now that you know cussing and swearing
at the comments section is not okay and
I don't I don't tolerate that kind of
things because you know it's it's not
appropriate things of you but um anyway
so so yeah like what its day the fourth
so i guess like the 11th is what i'm
going to be back and or well how about
another video uploaded but um yeah so
for those of you guys who are also
curious i'm going to be doing some stuff
at rob explains where I'm gonna be a bit
like a while like like three weeks since
I uploaded the video there but I'm doing
I've been organizing a series on the
history of World War two from like the
time that Hitler took power up until
like when Japan signed the instrument of
surrender on the USS Missouri um I've
been working on a series to try to you
know explain World War two because I
don't maybe it's just me but I feel like
there's a lot of like documentaries on
YouTube but there's no like there aren't
many people who have like created videos
explaining you know world war two and it
easy to understand why you know the
night of the Long Knives on the
Browncoats you know the fire the
Reichstag
the I guess the the beer pub the
bierstube riots having honorable what it
is but on the camera that's called off
top my head you know but like the you
know the there's all kinds of stuff in
World War two and in flushing it one
more to the conclusion World War to let
in the cold war which reshape you know
the really the global economic you know
thing whatever I'm tired it's like nine
o'clock at night and I haven't had any
coffee but yeah so I've been rambling
long enough so I'll be back on the 11th
don't be some videos coming on a while
explains the history of geek culture so
on and so forth I was going to put
gameplay to the videos right now I think
it'd just be kind of fun it is a history
geek culture why not have a gameplay and
yeah so I will see you guys in a week I
don't have you guys ever water wrestling
but Mick Foley back in the day he was
like bang bang he was one of my favorite
wrestlers of all-time in the nineteen
nineties anyway for real for true I'm
getting off here i'll catch you guys
later peace